so help me god congratulations mr
president
it is one of the traditions of america's
transition of power
the handshake between the incoming and
the outgoing president
four years ago donald trump and barack
obama
there will be no handshake this time and
the 46th president
pretty happy with that one of the few
things he and i have ever agreed on
it's a good thing him not showing up
he's been an embarrassment to the
country
embarrassed us around the world not
worthy not worthy to hold that office
if we were six months out we should be
moving
everything to get him out of office and
teaching them again
invoke trying to invoke the 25th
amendment whatever it took
to get him out of office but i am
focused now
on us taking control there are plenty in
washington who'd rather trump not make
it to inauguration day at all
congress is ready to impeach him for a
second time
so he can have a little asterisk in
history he's always wanted to do stuff
that's never been done before
there's never been a president impeach
twice before
so let's impeach him give him what he
wants
even after this belated concession my
focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
the pressure mounts to round off a week
that's defied belief
how about this from the speaker of the
house nancy pelosi on her conversation
with the head of the military
to discuss the available precautions for
preventing an unstable president
from initiating military hostilities or
accessing the launch codes and ordering
a nuclear strike
the situation of this unhinged president
could not be more dangerous
she wrote where protesters brought chaos
on wednesday
the preparations for the inauguration
have now resumed
the question is what donald trump's
absence from this inauguration stage
says to america is it the action of a
man who truly does now believe that joe
biden
is the legitimate next president or does
it encourage
those who've already been mobilized into
action by his words
the flag at the capitol flies at
half-mast in honor of police officer
brian siknik
killed in the mayhem on wednesday a
murder inquiry
has now begun
america is a very different place from
the one that witnessed the last change
over in the white house
trump's time is running out and the
reality tv president will want to make
sure he remains the star of this
show until the very end greg milam sky
news washington